uh now that you have corner seats I
gotta ask uh what's your hottest food
take so we're known on trash case for
shut up so okay so we're known on trash
taste for having some controversial food
takes do you have any like fruit takes
that you think are like a little bit
weird or
a little weird so why don't we give some
examples from the past okay so Connor
for example uh hates oranges oh like
with a passion like he doesn't just
dislike oranges he despises oranges yeah
you leave yeah I famously said on the
podcast once that all bread tastes the
same uh I do though oh my God oh my God
oh my God
this is amazing oh my God
okay thank you thank you I've been I
really like okay so you can you cannot
tell me you cannot like legitimately
tell me you came to the right side
Wonder Bread and pretzels taste the same
it's
like it's a name
you know like it's like you know with
cheese or not cheese I've never been
more happy in my life oh my God I'm
gonna get I can't am I gonna get
canceled for this
your idol career is over now
but no more bread commercials for me
all right I got off do you eat the pizza
crust I don't yes yes oh my God this is
this is one of my favorite moments on
trash days
right now because I mean that's where
you hold it it's a handle okay but but
Americans figured out that oh we we can
add dipping sauce like ranch or
something so that if you have just the
cross left then you can just dip it in
some ranch and you can eat it
deliciously or I should spread in it
yeah pizza's better with different
seasonings
wait wait she's on to something
something God damn bro what is your
least uh least favorite American food
least favorite I don't
like the least favorite my just like
no no two food but no food is um
egg whites uncooked egg whites uncooked
egg whites the texture is really weird
yeah it is a little plasticky isn't it
yeah and it's like Styrofoam and it's
like when I was really little I thought
it would look like a snail and ever
since then I just didn't need it nothing
that kind of looks like a snail and then
suddenly you know yeah because it's like
very slimy isn't it yeah do you eat
natto then I love natto yeah okay
finally a good food
thank God I was about to revoke
that was a test yeah no one in Japan
cares about bread we've seen we've seen
your Gaza sandwiches no one here
you don't [__] with the knot that's
facts how often do you get but uh get to
go back to America I haven't gone back
for four years four years 2019 was the
last year what was it like I guess like
once you the first time you went back to
LA after being here for however many
years you did I forgot like how so uh
friendly and unfriendly people in
customer service can be like you know
like it's both a good and bad place
like they're so polite in America it's
more like what do you want
take it yeah it's like I've I've like
noticed it's it's okay you know I know
why this is but it's like is this
customer does this customer service
position have a chance to tip if the
answer is yes you have you'll probably
have good customer service if you if the
answer is no you will have the most dog
[__] customer service of all time yeah
but like what what frustrates me more is
like you know the few who are like oh
yeah you know I'm I really want the tips
I'm going to try and be like a nice you
know uh weight or a waitress right but
then you know when you give them like a
lower tip than they expect they turn
around being like what do you mean you
didn't give me 18 I filled up your water
three times that's great service and I'm
like well you know yeah it is how it is
yeah I just want to say this this isn't
like a dig at people who work customers
they don't they don't get paid no no no
you guys are getting [__] over by the
system right yeah it's it's totally
systems yeah uh because yeah I've
noticed that you know when there's not a
chance of tip people don't care about
the customer service job because why why
wouldn't they yeah but yeah I mean going
back to America because I just came back
from America
um The Tipping the Tiffany culture has
gotten like even more insane exactly I'm
all for tips right but
you go to like a coffee shop or a
Starbucks and you order a coffee and the
only interaction you get is hey can I
have like a latte please venti or
[__] no it's not venti uh uh it's a
medium size yeah
um and they like turn like turn around
the tablet and the 20 tip is like there
by default
and I like it's just like a choice right
it's like 2010 yeah five or no tip yeah
and it's just like I don't want to be an
[__] and say no tip but also I kind
of feel like it's kind of like a dick
move to have it just like default on
like 20 yeah yeah yeah yeah yes that is
true so sure did you find any
experiences when you last went to
America that like changed when you you
had grown up there so when I was there I
would only go out with my parents as a
teenager so I never had to pay for
anything I actually didn't really know
the tip system
that's okay that's that privilege
yeah so I don't I don't know I don't I
almost never really went out so okay I
can't really
what's something you wish that Japan had
that has that La has
en has that La has yeah
um well that Japan should maybe
Implement perhaps
oh gosh I feel like there are many
things but it's like it's okay to say
nothing yeah
the no honor effects part no okay go
everything's like so everything's casual
yeah yeah I'm so bad at memorizing names
you know so but in Japan you can't be
like
a boss in English it could be like you
even if you don't know their name you
could be like hey how are you doing I
never thought about that because it's
the same way in like when I'm in
Thailand and I'm that I'm that
[__] who someone introduces
themselves and I make a mental note to
like not forget that name in the three
sentence I've forgotten it yeah me too
and I I actually I actually do this
thing where every time I meet someone or
I meet like a large group of people yeah
I'm like I always have my phone in my
hand and or in my pocket and what I do
is like I sneakily I sneakily write the
name down like a general description of
where I met them in a general
description of what they do right and so
when I get their phone number I I kind
of write it down as like it's like Jacob
and then in Brackets it's like uh the
guy I met at this place
and so every time like you know I'm
messaging because like you know after
you meet so many people you know doing
what we do right yeah there's only so
many subtle some that you can meet where
until you're like wait which subtle
sound was it or like is it a couple song
is it a Suzuki sound like I don't know
like because or because you know you
learn not on a first name basis in a lot
of ways in Japan but on a surname basis
right yeah so it just gets even more
confusing when you're like wait so so
you talked about you know me meeting a
subtles on the other day I'm pretty sure
I met like four of them last week and I
don't remember which one was which you
know